thank you for joining us at noon i'm  john langler breaking news from  brunswick georgia less than an hour ago  all three men charged in the death of  ahmad arbury were convicted of murder  took a jury there just 10 hours to reach  that verdict in the shooting of the  unarmed black jogger outside the  courthouse supporters of arbory and the  family of his family celebrated the  verdict greg mcmichael his son travis  and neighbor william bryan argued in  court they shot arbory last february in  self-defense the jury disagreed  we'd like to also say thank you and we  commend the courage and bravery of this  jury  to say  that what happened on february 23  2020 to ahmad aubry the hunting and  killing of ahmad aubry  it was not only morally wrong but  legally wrong  and we are thankful for that  all three men face life in prison